l'heure du journal de l'afrique sur
france24 très heureux de vous retrouver
le sénégal encore dans le flou 24 heures
après ces législatives majorité au
pouvoir et opposition revendique la
victoire chaque camp a fait de
l'élection un scrutin clé
l'onu en terre ces casques bleus cinq
soldats de la paix tués la semaine
dernière dans l'est de la rdc les
rassemblements contre la monusco se
poursuivent dans la région du nord kivu
ce timbre
c'est celui de clémentine haye et
fournit la soprano togolaise veut ouvrir
la voie à l'opéra classique dans son
pays le togo rencontre à la fin de ce
journal
il faudra s'armer encore d'un peu de
patience pour savoir quel camp a
remporté les législatives au sénégal les
résultats seront connus cette semaine en
attendant du côté de la présidence on
affirme qu'on a la majorité à
l'assemblée faux répond l'opposition qui
revendique aussi la victoire elle qui
fait imposer une cohabitation au
président macky sall marque plus
tard dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi
depuis le siège du parti la coalition
présidentielle revendiquent la victoire
aux élections législatives
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une victoire immédiatement contesté par
la principale opposition dans les rues
de dakar dimanche soir ces militants
revendiquaient même leur succès les
chefs de file appelle à attendre la
proclamation officielle des résultats
par la commission nationale indépendante
la cohabitation
inédite à
vous n'avez pas avec une majorité que
vous avez république et à sa trompe pas
nous avons des résultats sur la base de
bébé je répète tout
près de 7 millions de sénégalais étaient
appelés dimanche à renouveler le
parlement pour cinq ans lors d'un
scrutin à un tour cette élection c'est
figure de test pour le président macky
sall après la défaite de son parti dans
plusieurs grandes villes lors
d'élections locales en janvier
l'opposition veut imposer une
cohabitation au chef de l'état et espère
le faire renoncer à toute velléité de
candidature à un troisième mandat en
2024 macky sall laisse encore pour
l'heure planer le doute à dix neuf mois
de la présidentielle
ainsi des résultats sont égrainés ici et
là depuis la fin du scrutin seuls ceux
publiés par la commission électorale
feront foi ils sont attendus d'ici
vendredi à dakar l'envoyé spécial de
france 24 à washington
la cena donc commission électorale
nationale autonome est la seule
habilitée à donner les résultats
jusqu'ici il y avait une tradition
sénégalaise avec ces médias indépendants
notamment les radios qui distillait tout
au long de la soirée 1 2 électorale donc
hier dimanche jusqu'à lundi des
résultats bureau de vote par bureau de
vote qui faisait du sénégal un pays un
peu à part et qui faisait évidemment que
on avait des estimations assez fiable il
faut le dire dès le soir du premier tour
ici c'est pas le cas preuve peut-être
effectivement que les choses c'est assez
serré les résultats sont sans doute
assez serré pour le dire est que la
complexité aussi des listes fait que
peut-être il est beaucoup plus compliqué
de s'avancer sur un chiffre donc la cena
donnera normalement des résultats la loi
dit qu'ils ont 48 heures d'abord donc
mardi matin doit être le début des
annonces potentielle des résultats
provisoires officiels par contre et ils
ont jusqu'à vendredi pour les égrainé dé
façon officielle un scrutin vous l'aurez
compris décisive tant pour l'opposition
que pour le camp présidentiel et qui
fait office de répétition générale à
moins de deux ans de la présidentielle
pourtant il n'a pas à motiver les foules
ou un délai d'un électeur sur deux a
fait le déplacement pourquoi une si
faible participation quels enseignements
tirer de cette élection l'analyse de
mamadou diouf il est professeur d'études
africaines aux états unis
je pense que c'est une règle normale
d'un les élections que les deux ans
la victoire après le voit mais il est
très clair qu'aujourd'hui rien n'est
clair mais si le camp présidentiel
réclame proclame avoir gagné je pense
que le bouillon est en train de vie il
faut attendre le dépouillement à partir
de ce dépouillement on pourra
effectivement savoir qui a gagné qui a
pas gagné mais en tout cas les tendances
montre d'une part que l'opposition a
gagné dans les très grandes villes est
capable de vous donner les informations
nécessaires et dans l'autre la
discussion et au pour bizone des zones
périurbaines et épices au niveau rural
les jeunes de moins de 30 ans le présent
à peu près 70 % de la population sont
marginalisés ils sont en train de
prendre le destin mais c'est en train de
se battre la deuxième chose c'est qu'il
ya un resserrement si vous voulez de la
composition à des parties le sénégal à
400 parties les locales il y avait
quarante sept listes en compétition
cette fois ci on a eu que huit listes
cette compression donne
amplifie si vous voulez les capacités de
l'opposition qui est l'opposition la
plus je connais sable à pouvoir disant
conquête il est dans l'actualité du
continent également sept grands une
contre les nations unies qui ne faiblit
pas dans l'est de la rdc au
rassemblement de ces derniers jours
s'ajoute celui à béni ce lundi des
manifestants étaient a dispersés par des
tirs de sommation il tentait de
s'approcher d'une base de la monusco la
mission onusienne dimanche les casques
bleus de retour de gaza ont tué à la
frontière deux personnes et blessé 15
autres un incident grave et
inqualifiables a condamné l'onu
une semaine donc que les contestataires
réclament le départ de la monusco elle
est accusée de ne plus assurer la
sécurité de la population face aux
groupes armés durant ces manifestations
18 manifestants sont morts cinq soldats
de la paix leurs obsèques ont eu lieu ce
lundi camille nédélec
les casques bleus sont en deuil à goma
les soldats de l'onu ont rendu hommage à
leur collègue décédé trois ont été tués
pendant les manifestations anti monusco
la semaine dernière la mort d'une
dizaine de civils est aussi a déploré
l'onu dément leur avoir tiré dessus lors
des manifestations
justice doit être rendue à tous nos
collègues mais nations unies qui ont
perdu la vie et bien évidemment cette
justice doit être rendue à tous nos
frères et soeurs congolais s'ils
continuent de subir les affres de la
guerre
et qui sont les premières victimes
nous l'avons malheureusement vu encore
de ces terribles dérapages
et de ceux qui les initient des
installations de la mission des nations
unies ont été pillés par des
manifestants à goma lundi dernier
provoquant plusieurs jours de violence
contre l'onu il estime que la mission ne
secoue n'a pas su stabiliser la
situation sécuritaire du pays et ils
accusent les casques bleus de violence
leur revendication est simple que la
monusco son aïeul
[Applaudissements]
ont continué à me tuer on continue à
massacrer par moments au massacre même
déjà dans les parages direct plus
considérations dignes de france l'as
monaco ce qui nous fatigue et ce que
nous voulons plus voir sida c'est ça ce
qui est demandé au gouvernement des
ratés des résidents tous les contrats
qu'il a déjà signé avec la force de la
monusco la monusco est en place depuis
1999 et compte plus de 14 mille soldats
déployés en république démocratique du
congo
c'est ce qu'on appelle un mélange des
genres pour mieux faire à découvrir
l'opéra classique la soprano togolaise
clémentine iphone il eu fusionne avec
des percussions africaines voyez le
résultat reportage d'emmanuel se dit
une voie dans la catégorie soprano léger
la seule au togo
[Musique]
le timbre et la puissance de la voix de
clémentine iphone ou lui permettent de
chanter la flûte enchantée de mozart ou
la traviata de verdi
quand j'ai commencé à faire les premiers
ce chant solo dans ma cour elle il ya
des gens qui se moquaient de moi que
mais voilà tout tu vas aller où avec ça
mais aujourd'hui je pense que là le
public comprend de plus en plus que ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas vain ce que nous
faisons les gens commencent à s'y
intéresser à défaut de conservatoires
d'art lyrique ou de structures adaptées
la virtuose initient des chanteurs
d'église à l'opéra classique
il n'y a pas assez d'encadrement pour
aider nos les jeux intervilles en faire
une carrière musicale à attendre donc il
faut secondes
un travail personnel dans les paroisses
les jeunes choristes n'apprennent que
des chants d'église pour un email et
metz la soliste perfectionnent leur
technique vocale et élargi le répertoire
chez ce patient était trop fort non que
ça soit vraiment moule et moi même je
suis issue d'une chorale rapport à
l'amitié mais il se trouve que dans les
chorales on approfondit par le classique
dont de temps en temps nous programmant
des exercices et pendant mes concerts je
les programmes aussi à voir que moi je
ne vienne sur scène on afrique l'opéra
classique est encore un genre musical
méconnu alors pour obtenir l'adhésion du
public la soprano fusionne les sons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut au plus s'exprimer dans notre
langage c'est pourquoi maintenant on
amène à ajouter maintenant un peu de
rythme en à faut maintenant à tout ce
qu'on a pris qui est le classique avec
plus de trente ans de carrière musicale
cette virtuose et la plus grande soliste
togolaise d'opéra elle rêve d'emboîter
le pas de l'une des plus célèbres
soprano des 50 dernières années
l'américaine jessye norman
fin de ce journal merci aux équipes de
la rédaction à 7 ans régis merci de
votre fidélité au journal de l'afrique
retrouver nos six sur france 24 points
comme et nos réseaux sociaux le reste de
l'actu internationale c'est dans
quelques minutes
[Musique]